so yesterday was day one of the
republican national convention
and i've been struggling since it ended
at 11 p.m eastern last night
to figure out really how to cover it or
even talk about it
and when people do in public
what many of last night's republican
speakers did at the rnc
it would lead to a 9-1-1 call and
sometimes a 72-hour psych hold i mean
that's how outrageous what we saw last
night was
and in thinking how to cover it it's
sort of like do i
include a ton of clips do i include just
a few do i cover
every speaker or just the highlights do
i cover the broad strokes of what the
convention is doing
versus the minutia of what each speaker
is saying and
um i don't really know the answer so
i'll just give you a few of my thoughts
for today and then we'll see tomorrow
how we cover it
the theme yesterday was attack joe biden
but a little more specifically it was
rich people and trust fund kids
telling us that democrats are being mean
to capitalism
and that if joe biden gets elected
there's going to be some kind of a
marxist revolution in this country
and all of a sudden the united states
will be a communist
dystopia and on top of this
yesterday was riddled with identity
politics now
it was riddled with the same identity
politics that republicans claim to be
against one of my takeaways
from watching yesterday's rnc is i'm not
crowbaring
being hispanic into nearly enough
conversations
if i yesterday every speaker
who could justify being anything other
than a white person
mentioned it multiple times don jr's
girlfriend kimberly guilfoyle reminding
us multiple times that she's hispanic
nikki haley that she's i believe native
american
tim scott that he's black vernon jones
that he's black
i thought they were against identity
politics but i guess maybe they're only
against it when it's democrats but
clearly if i am to take a lesson from
republicans and why would i but if i
were to
in any opportunity that i have i should
be mentioning
by the way i'm hispanic did you know
that um
when i thought about yesterday's
presentations in total
i thought back to that bizarre time
where in 2012
at the rnc clint eastwood spoke to a
chair
and that was nothing as embarrassing and
humiliating
as that was for clint eastwood uh
whether he recognized it or not and i
think he's
since said he regrets it that was
nothing
eight years ago compared to yesterday's
first day of the republican national
convention
it was really one of the most deeply
dystopian events
and what made it more dystopian was the
degree to which republican voters loved
it i was looking on twitter i was
looking in some of the
recesses and cesspools of the pro-trump
internet and
people were just enamored with what they
saw
so let's look at some clips again i've
been debating how to cover this i think
for today i'm gonna do one
basically one wrap up clip and then
we'll do separate clips for specific
stories as needed
so each day we'll have sort of like the
main
wrap up and of course i'm not going to
be able to get to everything if you
don't like this way of covering it
just let me know and i'll look at look
at something else it's hours and hours
of stuff so it's very difficult to get
to all of it now two of the most
pyongyang
north korea-like propaganda speeches
came
from donald trump's son don jr and don
jr's girlfriend
former fox news hostess kimberly
guilfoyle recently recovered of course
from coronavirus now i'm going to start
with kimberly guilfoyle
because kimberly guilfoyle's speech was
the absolutely most outrageous thing
not just at last night's republican
national convention
but really at any ra republican national
convention that i've covered or watched
just screaming
uncontrollably seemed like a crazy
person and i'm not using that
pejoratively she
she seemed out of it she seemed ill
take a look at this first clip ladies
and gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
and then just go yeah then just going
fully
fascistic this is the language of
dictators
who just project onto others what they
actually want to do
take a look at this they want to destroy
this country and everything that we have
fought for
and hold dear they want to steal your
liberty
your freedom they want to control what
you see and think
and believe so that they can control how
you
live they want to enslave you to the
weak
dependent liberal victim ideology to the
point
that you will not recognize this country
or yourself
so this was outrageous i mean it was
you know it i you could analyze it
five or six different ways um it
was it mania was it delusional
was it that she chose to play a
character and the character was bonkers
i i just don't know and then she was
sort of
almost matched in a sort of different
tone and tenor
by donald trump jr her partner
um in full propaganda mode essentially
saying embrace the dear leader i mean
the shades of north korean propaganda
yesterday couldn't be missed take a look
at
don jr here imagine the life you want to
have
one with a great job a beautiful home a
perfect family
you can have it imagine the country you
want to live in
one with true equal opportunity
where hard work pays off and justice is
served with compassion and without
partiality
you can have it imagine a world where
the evils of communism and radical
islamic terrorism
are not given a chance to spread where
heroes are celebrated and the good guys
win
you can have it that is the life
that is the country that is the world
that donald trump and the republican
party are after
and yes you can have it
because unlike joe biden and the radical
left democrats
our party is open to everyone
everything you want can be given to you
by donald trump and donald trump only
but notice
it's not going to happen in four years
it's going to take trump
eight years to give you everything
nobody else can do it
and trump also couldn't do it in four
years which is why he needs another four
to give you all of these things
any time that you hear this one man
can give you everything stuff and we
heard it in 2016 when trump would say
only i can fix it that's an
authoritarian red flag
and likewise the projection
was just off the wall kimberly guilfoyle
projecting onto joe biden the
authoritarianism which is
actually the hallmark of donald trump
and then they brought out a
cuban-american
named maximo alvarez and as i've
mentioned
before on the program as a hispanic
american myself remember if the rnc has
taught me anything it's i need to
constantly talk about how i'm hispanic
the only latin american group in the
united states that has any significant
amount of conservatism is
cuban-americans
all other latino groups are
overwhelmingly liberal in the united
states
they brought out a cuban-american maximo
alvarez who equated joe biden
to fidel castro if you can imagine take
a look speaking to you today because
i have seen people like this before i've
seen movements like this before
i've seen ideas like this before
and i am here to tell you we cannot let
them
take over our country i heard the
promises of fidel castro
and i can never forget all those who
grew up around me
who looked like me who suffered
and starved and died because they
believe those empty promises
now anybody who has any connection to
reality
would know that there is no similarity
between center-left joe biden who's been
pulled
a little bit further to the left over
the last three months there's nothing
linking him to fidel castro
nor to venezuelan leaders hugo chavez or
nicolas maduro but the constant imagery
yesterday linking biden to venezuela
linking biden to cuba to socialism to
marxism
meanwhile the progressive left is
disappointed that biden isn't really
that progressive i mean it's just a
fantasy world
that this convention was based on now i
don't want to give the next two people
too much attention because it's
borderline
criminal that they're even part of the
republican national convention
but the mccloskeys this is the couple
from st louis who brandished firearms at
black lives matter protesters
they were invited to speak this is a
couple their lawyers
who are known only for pointing long
guns
or i think it was one long gun and a
handgun at protesters ain't sent in st
louis a few weeks ago they spoke i'm
only going to give you
five seconds of them that they don't i'm
not i'm just refusing to give you more
here is i believe it's patricia
mccloskey the wife
saying that joe biden wants to end the
suburbs
to abolish the suburbs altogether by
ending
single-family home zoning it's really an
indictment of everything that
these people were even speakers
at the convention and then finishing out
the
joe biden will abolish stuff phase of
our review
here is natalie harp claiming that joe
biden would essentially abolish
doctors people wouldn't be able to have
doctors anymore if joe biden were
president
god forbid what the next four years
would look like
for in joe biden's america china would
control our drug production
we'd be one step closer to
government-run health care
we wouldn't just be unable to keep our
doctors we'd be lucky if we could see
any doctor
we would be lucky if we could see any
doctor
under joe biden says natalie harp now
there were many more speakers quite
frankly i don't think i can tolerate too
much more
but the themes were claimed that there
was no policy discussed at the dnc
and then don't talk about any policy
disparage the dnc
as being just about criticizing trump
but then spend the entire time merely
criticizing joe biden as a marxist and a
communist and i'm truly questioning
number one the future of this country if
60 million people see this and then vote
for it in november
and number two whether i'm actually
going to be able to make it through
three more days of this garbage i'm
going to try
but this was truly i mean it's it's this
isn't healthy this is really bad this is
very very bad
and then to top it off here is my
absolute
favorite moment from day one of the rnc
donald trump staged these little
conversations with different
at one point it was with workers at
another point it was with former
hostages the idea was to put trump
in front of people and make him seem
like a relatable normal guy
and at one point one of the workers that
was part of the group that trump was
speaking to
said i'm a custodian at a school trump
doesn't know what a custodian is
it's just the epitome of a
privilege where anybody who went
to public school or even to private
school and and was just like enmeshed in
what was going on
you would know the custodian cleans the
school it's not like trump maybe thinks
a financial custodian of assets or
something
the worker says i'm a custodian trump
says oh and what do you do as if
you know i'm dropping everything because
this is so crazy take a look at it
how about you i'm a custodian at the
post office as well
what do you do exactly clean up
everybody's mess and everybody's germs
and
all that that that world that profession
will never be out of business
you know that right just a microcosm
of the entire republican national
convention day one
rich people and trust fund babies
claiming to be all about workers and the
middle class
and fear-mongering that joe biden will
make us marxist
while knowing absolutely nothing about
the middle class and workers so tonight
we go on to day two
everything is always scheduled but could
change
tonight it's melania trump secretary of
state mike pompeo senator rand paul
that covington kid nick sandman eric
trump
and tiffany trump i will see you tonight
8 30 pm eastern time on youtube and
twitch
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave
me is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video